vous êtes sur france 24 et vous avez
raison bienvenue dans votre journal de
l'afrique à la une ce soir la gambie
prêt à juger yahya jammeh l'ancien
direct dit dictateurs et des dizaines de
personnes sont accusées de multiples
crimes pendant ses plus de 20 ans à la
tête du pays
le camouflet infligé par la puissante
centrale syndicale tunisienne lui gtt au
président cède ce dernier avait proposé
un dialogue qui ne répond pas aux
attentes des forces nationales
explications à suivre dans ce journal
est une légende de la musique un
chanteur sénégalais la voix unique qui
avec son orchestre transporte depuis 37
ans ce sont paul juillet la
indéfinissable dérives du foot a
jusqu'au plateau l'emilien baba maal
était notre invité extrait de notre
entretien assure
la justice gambienne a décidé de
poursuivre son ancien président pour de
multiples crimes commis sous ses vingt
ans de règne près de 250 personnes
seraient mortes sous sont sous le régime
du dictateur et à dia mais cette
perspective de procès est un soulagement
pour les victimes comme nous le raconte
notre correspondant dans la région sarah
sakho
le gouvernement gambien a accepté toutes
les recommandations de la commission
vérité et réconciliation en clair des
poursuites contre 70 personnes dont yaya
jammeh l'ancien dictateur qui vit
actuellement en exil en guinée
équatoriale le ministre gambien de la
justice daouda diallo a précisé qu'un
parquet spécial sera créé pour mener ces
poursuites un tribunal spécial également
au sein de la justice gambienne qui sera
basée en gambie mais at il précisé des
audiences pourront se tenir dans
d'autres pays aujourd'hui en tout cas la
nouvelle est accueillie avec soulagement
par les victimes les victimes qui n'ont
cessé de dénoncer ces derniers mois un
manque de volonté politique et qui
craignaient même un coup d'arrêt à cette
justice transitionnelle rappelons le la
commission vérité et réconciliation a
enquêté pendant plus de deux ans elle a
entendu quelques 400 témoignages de
victimes de présumé coupable des
témoignages accablants qui ont montré
dont qui ont dévoilé toutes les
violences les exactions commises sous le
régime de yahya jammeh la commission a
d'ailleurs compté au moins 250 morts 250
personnes assassinées entre les mains de
l'état et de ses agents
c'est un retour qui posent de plus en
plus de questions celui des réfugiés
nigériens dans leur pays les autorités
locales du nord-est nigeria encouragent
leurs ressortissants à revenir sur leur
terre
malgré la menace toujours présente de
boko haram dans la zone le niger le
nigeria et le hcr sont en phase de
finalisation d'un accord pour organiser
ce retour mais déjà plusieurs milliers
de nigérians passent la frontière
reportage d'harold girard à diffa au
niger à quelques kilomètres seulement du
niger
cette équipe du hcr est chargé de se
renseigner sur la situation de ceux qui
ont fui boko haram au nigeria
books are many kaloum y a tout perdu en
2015 lorsque les attaques du groupe
terroriste se multipliaient ses deux
filles ont été kidnappés
avec une arme
entre eux
il en est relatif allons-y laisse
comme beaucoup de réfugiés malgré la
menace de nouvelles attaques la crise
alimentaire qui frappe le niger le
pousse à envisager un retour dans l'état
de borno au nigeria dont il est
originaire
ici où sont les champs ou plus
travailler dans l'agriculture
même si tu as l'opportunité de
travailler dans un champ
le hcr de son côté ne peut pas interdire
ces départs mais doit informer les
candidats au retour des dernières
attaques jihadiste sur les routes qu'il
compte emprunter
l'accord entre le niger le nigeria et le
hcr n'a pas encore été conclu mais les
incitations retour des autorités et de
l'état de borno fonctionne environ 4000
nigérians sont déjà retournés chez eux
depuis le début de l'année du côté du
hcr on envisage toutes les possibilités
même celle d'un échec de la
réinstallation au nigeria des mondiaux
civil détruits c'est vraiment une
situation qui est imprévisible dans la
région deux fois au moment où nous
savons qui est
le corps par une nonne étatiques sont
toujours en action sont toujours en
mouvement avec des questions aussi
probabilité qui aura une citation de
retour même si on sait que les autorités
environ 130 mille réfugiés nigérians
vivent aujourd'hui dans la région de
diffa au niger
80% des volontaires pour un retour dans
leur pays souhaitent partir
immédiatement
l'actualité s'est invitée au 57e
assemblées générales de la banque
africaine de développement à accra au
ghana avec la menace de la crise
alimentaire sur le continent conséquence
directe de la guerre en ukraine
l'afrique doit aussi faire face aux
changements climatiques qui menacent les
récoltes les précisions de notre envoyé
spécial maires mm la halle avec célia
car a fait
deux ans que la banque africaine de
développement n'a pas tenu en présentiel
ces assemblées générales en raison de la
crise sanitaire l'occasion justement de
dresser un premier bilan de cette crise
post qu'ovide un bilan sombre puisque la
croissance économique sur le continent a
chuté résultat 30 millions d'africains
vivent dans l'extrême pauvreté et la
situation ne risque pas de s'améliorer
en raison du contexte international
selon le président de la bad ass 30
millions de tonnes de denrées
alimentaires en provenance de russie et
d'ukraine n'arriveront pas cette année
en afrique ce qui laisse planer le
spectre de la crise alimentaire mais le
président de la banque africaine de
développement se dit optimiste pour lui
la peur n'est pas une statistique il ne
faut pas avoir peur il faut avoir un
plan et son plan tient en deux mots
autosuffisance alimentaire pour lui
l'afrique ne m'en diras pas sa
nourriture elle la produira pourquoi il
souhaite développer le secteur agricole
mais ce secteur agricole devra faire
face à un autre problème de taille celui
du changement climatique on
passe à la tunisie où la puissante
centrale syndicale du gtt a refusé de
prendre part au dialogue avec le
président khaled avait proposé ce
dialogue dans le but de fonder une
nouvelle république après s'être arrogé
les pleins pouvoirs en juillet 2021 lily
à blaise
c'est un durcissement claire du ton de
la part de la centrale syndicale du jt
et qui jusqu'à présent était ouverte au
dialogue avec la présidence de la
république mais qui a réaffirmé à
travers ses membres dans une conférence
de presse ce mercredi son refus de
participer au dialogue national à cause
de l'exclusion de nombreux partis
politiques mais aussi d'une partie de la
société civile elle ne discutera pas de
dialogue national avec le président de
la république tant qu'il n'y a pas de
changement dans la façon de faire de la
présidence on n'est pas confiant qu'on
va faire marche arrière parce que il a
pris des décisions
auparavant son changer d'avis mais
maintenant on est un peu déçu au lieu de
l'arrivée aux grèves il faut négocier
maintenant il n'ya pas de 2 go si cette
négociation fiable est positif on a le
droit
de faire plus sion gtt reste encore
ouverte à un dialogue avec le
gouvernement sur les négociations
sociales et pour éviter l'éventualité
d'une grève générale dans le secteur
public comme elle l'avait menacé lundi
dernier
aujourd'hui ce sont aussi des partis
politiques qui ont appelé à boycotter le
dialogue national proposé par le
président de la république et le
référendum prévu pour la fin juillet une
situation politique donc tendue pour un
calendrier très serré puisque les
réformes constitutionnelles doivent se
faire d'ici le 20 juin afin de pouvoir
être soumise à ce référendum prévu pour
la fin juillet nous avons mené invité
exceptionnel ce soir sa voix son
charisme sa présence scénique sa
générosité tous les distingue baba maal
est né il y à 68 ans dans le fouta au
sénégal voilà plusieurs décennies qu'il
transporte partout dans le monde sait y
est là ce son particulier tout couleur
dont il est le roi incontesté et nous
lui avons demandé justement son apport
de la musique africaine dans le monde me
dit
je pense qu'il faut d'abord que qu'on
arrive à convaincre que la culture
occupe une place importante dans
l'épanouissement de nos sociétés donc
dans nos communautés et sera toujours
été là c'était présente depuis la nuit
des temps mais le monde change et il
faut gagner son importance dans
lorenzaccio même de la société je pense
que c'est là où l'industrie ou même
peut-être l'industrialisation de la
musique africaine peut quand même donné
un coup de pouce pour que la musique
soit reconnue parce qu'on tout le monde
sait que il à cette question des gains
de d'apport et de reconnaissance donc
qui est là merci nous laissons cette
demi degré ca
son état primaire donc de d'entraînement
donc d'entretenir les gens tous cours
n'auront pas cette reconnaissance que
nous souhaitons mais alors je me
demandais ce que vous avez encore des
rêves d'autres collaborations que vous
avez pas encore exploré à la mène le
monde et est immense en parlant de
culture ya la musique de de l'asie
présente de l'inde qui me tente beaucoup
encore l'asie m'intéresse beaucoup à la
musique latino américaine que j'ai pas
encore beaucoup exploité et qui se
trouvera dans mon prochain album et
notre projet d'essai en voyage on voit
la découverte de la musique du monde
mais la source le point de départ c'est
la musique a plus qu un fait et c'est
ainsi que nous refermons ce journal
l'afrique merci à tous ceux qui nous ont
suivis partout dans le monde au fouta en
particulier podor matam caennais lumumba
rester avec nous car l'activité continue
sur france 24 ans quitte en musique avec
quelques notes de ba va mal
[Musique]